welcome to this video no I'm sorry this
will be M the war zone final I'm not I'm
not sure what's up with my voice yeah
but I'm sorry hope this gets better I
got a slight cool but now when you
actually start talking you you see that
it's or you hear that it's not so great
actually I still try to to make this
video alright so Danny was on final 10
seconds to go so on I'll start right now
here we go all right let's double it up
and here we go this was quick alright I
like the table let's finish quick whip
ok yeah limbs oh sort of let's see what
you place should be too yeah I've got a
kind of bogo Indian set up we had night
recapture yam position is some closed
damn is trying to quickly open it up
down our position see also rather solid
though to get a knight to e5 for
beautiful night post yeah on the tempo
on the bishop and now I can walk down
the queenside now you won't win the
spawn not easily at least
yeah let's secure the kingside okay yeah
don't want to exchange this really not
sure that I have much choice Quinn g5
you most likely retweet the Queen yeah
let's color yeah it looks am looks a bit
dangerous not sure if there's anything
threatening really all right Scott quite
a number of pieces and the attack and
it's may be content with a draw can I go
here probably hmm yeah doesn't do much
the smooth but it's still one quite
annoying o gauge for I can take on g2
okay so yeah now i'm probably winning
position wise but i'm not even
yeah now it should be women yeah Queen
have to check mate we and this was very
very tough probably losing at least on
time in a way alright next game yeah he
called a stratagem ok efore let's try to
get something going quickly here scotch
scotch opening yeah the some nights you
for whom okay let's let's cover this I
play this stuff myself so it difficult
to play this now from the other side
Cara Black seems okay
hmm no idea something went wrong there I
guess okay maybe take the chance to to
advance the pawn not quite sure where
it's night should go of course I'm not
attacking it immediately but I will ya
know it's in a pin that's what's the
idea yeah now the night is very very
badly placed on each form if he doesn't
play c5 now I play Knight B 3 ok yeah I
can take it come by have three so on the
King here night yo if you saw that my
dears now to protect the pawn and here's
no way together yeah now i'm attacking
g7 so kingi three-year king g3 and he
needs to drop back yeah but this
shouldn't be too bad also grabbing all
the poems plays some oops just gave me
this let's take that maybe I'd even
something better some some meeting idea
try to to get a meetin using the g poem
gee 697 something like this there must
be a maid somewhere hmm cost us rook f7
okay where is the mate yeah probably
days until I again can go here use this
check and now take the rook also not too
bad yeah get a new queen okay so three
are three it's not too bad I'm used to
very bad starts in this tournament yeah
maybe some some crazy gambit stuff wins
quicker but I simply cannot do this I
play some incorrect opening I don't know
like I'll bin saw some other crap i
usually simply spend too much time in a
bad position yeah okay 11 deform it
works with the NIMS oh also Wow ok again
this was check and take here I could
have taken the root cause oh ok and not
too bad yeah my voice is getting a tad
better but still sounds weird I guess ok
a queen's gambit I don't don't do the
exchange again last couple of games
weren't so great ok this guy is pretty
high rated
yeah I've got a very classical tab of
Queens gambit okay you need to play a
6cm this is some strange move play know
this and it gets a bit tricky for black
Bishop c7 whoops yeah I was threatening
this not sure why and now the queen is
trapped it was very bad anyway but the
queen is still queen yeah I need to play
86 on Queen it for I cannot take because
of okayed a light and just 90 yeah the
Italian mmm I think I can take him yet
for to prevent Bishop g5 who 95 or some
models greatest idea ever really light
will get kicked with c4 so not sure this
was also so great ok let's take care
rook dat can take on c6 mm-hmm Queen
Elsa's got 94 hmm
slightly slightly annoying let's click
here trying to speed up development some
others didn't really work out why does
sound certainly better here with the evo
so nothing completely terrible but here
x is an issue let's try rupee eight
nonetheless but um yeah this is a
complete exchange of everything Oh what
else ya cannot down play without this we
can pick b5 an f5 and then try to in
wait with the King and waiting now I can
get a pest poem with age 5 she'll be
winning really huh yeah out of nothing
yet this was of course a draw so in game
okay yeah it looks nice but it's it's 20
points nothing at this point at least I
don't need to come from far behind as
I'm used to so let's see one if i yam
now I'm forced to play this okay this
isn't to to bed trying to provoke see 60
Knight e5 looks dead dangerous for black
tion dead and i can take here and take
the seven right yeah okay you should be
five check really helped so just here
yeah well everything wins this also I
don't know he needs to take care and
I've just got an extra piece yeah and he
is also ice cut the king in the middle
but in preparing ok take care exchange
Queens yeah it would help if he would
resign but it's not not quite clear what
kind of advantage you must have that
people actually resign a game simply
cost time for the tournament
yeah finding up on b6 and will win this
probably can also take here no f5 is
gone yeah the simpler costs costs yeah
of course I want to draw okay I probably
hit the wrong button yeah this cost just
one minute and which you can play
another game okay I am maybe I can can
score quick one with my special special
opening here the counter gambit with
their five irritating people yeah now
why it must play in 91 and 95 and black
and some basically winning already
sometimes they try Bishop c4 but just
this is just completely incorrect this
piece sacrifice can ya can also drop
back and also take I mean just then have
the e4 pawn extra and also big advantage
in the center
yeah the easiest is now to just get
along prevent any kind of crazy attacks
and just remove the you the extra porn
okay yeah p6 is my idea get to get the
Queen's off ok ok let's let's use the
some the sepan 92 now threaten some to
win another exchange probably needs to
know ok ok let's get all this doubt that
there's any kind of compensation Bishop
c4 yep kicking out safety one don't see
any any threat really
seaforth singing and rookie one also
quite a serious threat okay you have
this once I want the house not the house
the house needs to learn yeah give the
Queen now okay damn still on the lead
okay again somewhat better oops c4 was
my intention of course yeah this is a
somewhat lame opening now kind of London
system of this C 3 against the g6 setup
so at least you should place you for but
ok c2 c3 was just a mouse lip not much
you can do about that ok but though it's
not real it's not so bad I'll have some
some play on the queenside should I play
before yacon he can take it but this
should give me some play on the coincide
don't mind that too much yeah but now
I've got nite nite c-46 this idea yeah
it's not a brilliant position but can
play it towers irritates me if I make
those mouths lip at a very early stage
even if the not so Tara will chastise
I'm still completely irritated and again
this is really crappy looking game to
get 96 in
at least get my pieces active the night
only one is especially especially bad at
least it seems to irritate them ya black
ass suddenly okay yeah but that's of
course somewhat messy position to take
care not take b7 make some use of this
rook yeah at least this piece shot
should irritate them yeah taking the
person I want to play Knight see to this
night needs to move oops I can just take
the Queen okay here this was a bit lucky
irish a key game yeah well those small
slip saw Liam likes III always and get
me out of rhythm oops King f1 not sure
this was a planned move hmm ok let's try
to to open up the King here okay alright
so how do i use the FO cannot play d the
deep on
so the night air for coming hmm yeah
cause my complete madness what you play
but the test some points yeah very weird
yeah of course you can play this but I
can exchange sec the exchange em get
some not at all clear yeah of course
time is a huge problem I spent ages on
this this nonsense hotel to play now am
pinned here unbelievable okay yeah this
is just a fog I hope there's no insane
safe I'm no but then okay this will be
tricky with the time at least yeah I've
got pretty good control here at least
cannot turn do so much yeah I want want
pieces to coordinate and don't like the
poem
down to 19 seconds unbelievable probably
need to meet here to to win otherwise
the timer son oops okay let's let's grab
the rope no manage not over there we
keep this nonsense all right ah this was
an expensive game took ages and it
didn't even win against this nonsense
okay yeah I spent unbelievable amount of
time in the opening I'm just just laid
yet sometimes you just need to play
whatever okay this this opening which
isn't really good for white but not not
so easy to refute if you've got them
when it sits yeah this is our book and
it's it's just lost for Wyatt close to
but then what is the g6 g6 I think it's
cisek this line is basically I'm close
to being lost but you need to know all
the moves I'll find them my deaf five
man I'm hope this is okay I hope this is
okay Gaia he's got he's got all this
silly tricks huh
hey yeah this looks like some sort of
taken maybe I'd any Queen f5 earlier
maybe I'm not sure simply forgot how
this is played and it's obviously it
would two minutes thought so easy to
find maybe this is still are still fine
there should be six normal I want to
play Bishop L rooks Roxy 7i Roxy seven
is not even playable anyway okay Queen B
7 i've got quincy seven maybe I can
still summer holders I want to see how
does he keep the poor not at all i can
just take it right wow I survive this I
hope wow yeah okay I somehow it did was
working out but I already forgot the
forgot the lines you draw of course not
come on I really hate this it's just
nonsense why should you want to why
should I draw
some people are really annoying I mean
they they keep pressing draw draw draw
for whatever reason and i really don't
know why okay so hmmm should shouldn't i
have some discovery yeah okay well this
should lead to a nice position anyway
okay okay it's got a very weird
configuration on the queenside which
really looks like it's not working at
all but i'd see a refutation get this in
a pin threatening 96 which is ignored
completely why can i doona can play this
right did some it's this yeah now the
rook is saying and basically yes no
moves at all you can no exchange but
then it's a huge fork yeah the eight is
also hanging I mean this was the problem
please you lose this as well
yeah it's just an extra look let's play
this way it should be easier yeah of
course is not resigning I mean it's
pretty high rated you should understand
the mechanics of this tournaments really
but obviously not yeah this team a lot
made yeah I'm on second place some guy
in the head of me but while i'm in there
i mean i even managed to get the rating
above 2500 tournaments this is really
rare okay what do we got here nimsay
catalan what is he playing he's not
playing at all which isn't a good sign
okay maybe I can drink something oops
sorry I get this with rather loud so the
names Oh play a rail line here trying to
irritate him a bit okay you form this is
this is rare really
don't know I mean g5g for probably wins
the default pun but I don't want such a
messy position mm-hmm then I first take
here yeah okay Kelly Five Guys ideas
probably to play g-form look Sam Ted
crazy but I'd slopped not a bad idea try
to get counter play in the sand down
okay if I take a form yeah I can play
can play push-up d3 but I have to check
here and the night before this looks
good it's got all kinds of stuff in this
diagonal f5 to to be one and um maybe
needs to play the move like some move
like Bishop d3 now yeah now can I take
now on on g3 if I take on a let's just
just just take here this is okay and now
back attacking this and I'm just trying
to take it and Bishop f5 okay if you
move the porno I have Bishop f5 winning
the the exchange or the rock whatever
yeah the gphone hmm it is dangerous i
played this very very quickly
should have thought more about this okay
if you place bishop age 6 i'm and i'm
willing to sacrifice something here not
sure the Sun this should work check here
the app should should be enough reading
time wise all right yeah I was tricky
okay here's some guy was 1600 with 11
out of 11 all right I mean it's possible
theoretically if you if you just started
out on chess cube and you start with a
very low rating of course and you feel
really strong player I'm it's possible
but it looks weird okay I didn't want to
take on p 7 others can get to get tricky
rather yeah try to get get something
like this in Knights six almost wins the
Queen now threatening nights is six
Bishop a six winning the Queen and if
i'm not mistaken I'm ruining the Queen
yeah told the Queen noise
you can maybe play it something like
Bishop before and safe yeah okay yeah
this guy with set 11 out of 11 s really
fun this guy usually resides against mia
i know my might be my guys here ok son
let's hope for a quick game ok it's not
really caring about the center I white
butt white butt white that can give this
check here and get his King in and I'm
in a weird position yeah h5 coming yeah
now he's got kissed he doesn't really
have a square for the for the bishop
this was rook was hanging if I may be
tried to open up as as much as possible
I like rook each age 32 f 3 this would
be nice okay i justjust his check and
now he's he's in the middle of of
everything here
yeah maybe nice attacking position
everything else fails i'm ok ok i can't
play this again now we need to give the
Queen and mate this is working nicely I
mean cannot hope for more I think I only
butchered this one game with the artists
draw where I spent so much time in the
opening at the center game Queen DS t 2
is strange yuly go to e3 and try to
Castle quickly a gas long quickly can I
just take don't see why not 25 I've got
down 27 ok now I can just just develop
56 crystal six right
Bishop a 6mm Bishop au 6m can can go
here before I can take is in this
diagonal so i get to get something back
or I have a discovery nice one if you
look to f4 if you move the rock rook f
ing for all it's nice wow really now I
can just and you can just go here she
should be too bad I'm 95 maybe maybe at
95 all right let's let's try something
on f 2 all the way back f 2 is so just
just staying mm of course think I'm may
be threatening rook f2 now
huh have to okay oops oops mmm okay what
is this now I don't know I didn't want
to play this hey I can drop back it's
not at the end of the world okay let's
let's play it simple trying to take here
and then get something on f2 I need to
make sure that I'm not mated okay when
the Queen come on oops oh I really
didn't leave blah i played this really
terrible giving you all kinds of chances
also the time it's a big problem
unbelievable with this is a winning end
game it is not really quick nice didn't
really expect to win this all right yeah
sometimes so it's it's not working out
nicely I said 16 minutes left and i'm
pretty nicely in the lead
hmm ok old be known here well ok let's
look some very weakening on the on the
light squares oopsie I've I'm lucky yeah
I'm really lucky here just a mouse slip
across him I just wanted to retake ok
yeah ok I need some need some luck as
well yeah y ou K no it them basically
almost yeah almost kind of winning this
position with extra porn and you can
complete control over fo SC 4 and so on
that winning is a bit much but it's very
close can I I need f3 possibly yeah no
it cannot really cavity 676 should be
should be gone yeah let's just drop this
back and completely control everything
don't care so much about winning even
more I can just take f6 all the time I
was so busy with this this nice
maneuvers that I completely forgot to
take this all right yeah i was thinking
about getting something okay this is
made yeah complete with game yeah i'm
leading by almost 50 points it's about
two games two wins it's not bad I'm not
doing anything completely stupid I
should manage to
21 that thing ok on the Evans gambit oh
it's not to remember this stuff and two
minutes chest is not so lazima yeah it's
a pretty sharp line maybe I should have
given should have done for something
else yeah it's so yeah I've got the
extra porn on a typical evidence extra
portlet white has some some active
pieces it's probably not enough
compensation but he's got a bit of
activity ok let's get rid of pieces on
always nice feature about having an
extra front of you don't really know
what to do trade off things may be here
King f2 I've got 93 it's a nice little
trick not exactly a wassup to Howard
y'all still d3 is a nice square taking
the bishop and everything looks very
irritating I cannot take care now yeah
why not now i'm getting the Bishop to b6
looks good
all right yeah very nice night you can I
take care okay so first this check hmm
we should try to cover this first yeah
yeah there is some activity with the
rooks yeah must have made some mistakes
they obviously there was at one point
there was just nothing but I have some
play myself I can try on to get on the
second rank it is not terribly quick I
know is in a pin with 93 coming you have
extra it's not exactly quick not the
fastest player ever but at least I can
speed up a bit right yeah this guy was
16 out of 16 is on second place I mean
if he wins this thing that will be there
will be investigations
let's put it that way it's simply for
normal 1600 player here it's simply not
possible to make 16 out of 16 it's not
possible even if they're if they play
the tournament of their life it's simply
not not doable ok while I'm chatting
away here this guy played a really
strange set up against the name zone I
mean well he played the names oh I
played a very strange set up against my
line him this is basically already
winning for white I've got monster
center and the pin and everything it's a
really a dream position that's that's
reasonable really cannot cannot do
anything yeah and now I can go here and
just win have six on f5 a player 5 if
everything else fails so complete
opening disaster all right I really hope
I win this I mean of course I want to
win anyway but this guy was 1600 and you
need to be prevented I mean probably if
it's if it's some weird cheating stuff
that none they alarm get disqualified
yeah disguised on moving is great
unbelievable so 17 out of 17
yeah he doesn't move great for whatever
reason it's called 138 points is very
close yeah besides the 1700 gaiam
there's kingscrusher following also
close of course on this is just
completely unfair here I'll only get
single points for this yeah okc and
mango very close yeah it's all about the
last couple of games and this is just
bad wait the game stakes he has accepted
but now doesn't move this is weird or at
least I get double the points and don't
get it it's also not too great them to
watch her two minutes I could sing but
with my own voice yeah heard by the
coated one would even be M worse than
than usual alrighty lose some time now
yeah people say isn't a cheetah Mia
whatever don't don't care need to win
the rest here which is nice some quick
resigns k reversed the reversed Grand
Prix Wow don't see long castle that very
often in this open you know this opening
I mean often is good i never saw it
before ok i will try to open up his skin
yeah i saw that even if it wasn't a
blunder I'm to get the blinds open up
quickly here should be three now
threatened it's double am oh I can take
on f6 mmm now maybe it's not so terrible
i wanted to flush the night here g4 wow
you can get big aplenty 5d form there
should be three coming just fire come on
everything on the king okay let's see
what what's possible now
didn't really get your lady I just hope
that there is something Queen B 7 check
King c3m don't see anything great really
yeah it's probably just covering
everything I may connect another I have
neither form f9f form
mmm it is dangerous can you 39 f for get
this Bishop and yeah really hard to
believe now i'm getting all my pieces in
the attack this is sam this must be
winning hum bhi to trick me don't be too
right now queen a to mate well this was
important most probably could could
easily have lost this was very gambling
game ok with two minutes left i'm
meeting with parents yeah and I'm lucky
usually this guy resins 44 points come
on I need to win this two-minute
something at this guy is the one who
lost this news oh just before try that
try that again let's see okay now is
that playing differently I mean you
needed to this was custom on a playable
what you did neide f5 coming okay need
to be a quickie em I mean it's a not
much time left I think you needed to
play you for this one will get dangerous
Queen age 6 hmm what a weird game yeah
probably hisses is fine now yeah of
course this was all a bit dictated by
and by the time situation in the
tournament can I wise now I was he was
on a 3 this is a problem otherwise I
could have sacrificed goodness i could
have sacrificed some non 1g six hmm of
course I'm still leading hopefully I
don't need to win in this game because I
probably lose h5m Kevin's lost anyway
what can I do check here doesn't help
yeah yeah I think five thousand is this
first place yes yeah I'll manage to to
bring this to bring the soul shaky game
at the end now let's get a bit nervous
at the end what can you do but ok let's
check quickly the the final standings
I'm manage 25 games 350 points and I
didn't did I lose the game you know I
don't think so i think just justice this
draw ended this one at the end a lot
show but i'm pretty satisfied
i'm mateus 25 27 m i mean i won like 40
points and this stage is difficult okay
and they see they say the second place
is some some some just um it's a good
player I was a new em with the new
handle 20 out of 20 still so quite much
yeah thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it and yeah I'll be back soon
with new videos